[Music]
hi
rob lowes this is karen from houston
texas
now everyone thinks that you never age
i get that all the time but you looking
into the mirror seeing your own flaws
what tips would you tell 23 year old rob
um about skin care for your face
i was just curious i have children i try
to tell them
they listen they may not listen but i
would like to know what you think
let me know literally well karen thank
you for listening and calling in and
because you asked
um i i felt the same thing raising my
kids
um and that's one of the reasons i
started my own skincare line
which is called profile and you can get
it online
um because i had people taking care of
me since i was
a young actor you wake up in the morning
you go on the set and you know people
start
taking care of your skin the makeup
people do that that's their job
and i have had people doing that for me
since i was 15.
now i'm 57 and
i really think that's made a big
difference and of course what are they
doing
they are putting sunscreen on you number
one number one
number one number one what 15 year olds
putting sunscreen on
nobody and we now know that those
gnarly sunburns you get when you're a
kid that we all used to get and laugh
about or whatever
try to get putting crisco on us or
whatever to get tan
those are what give you skin cancer
later in life
so it's never too early to start taking
care of your skin and and um
it's one of the reasons why i i was
really trying to develop a
spf skincare protection moisturizer
which we we do have in the line and it's
great
so um yeah your instinct is right get
the kids
uh investing in their skin now
because once you start seeing the damage
it's too late but thanks for listening
that was a really good question